hello and welcome to this video on Boyd
khaimah playing d4 and the London it's a
nice surprise that I have prepared
Bishop g4 he completely like I think
just 993
no no reaction whatsoever I can't yeah
well here I'm trying to be ambitious
let's try to be very active and attack
the London system Queen should be three
this is a mess is also quite ambitious
so let's see this is a funny funny
position it looks it looks a bit like a
like the Queen's Gambit Rogozin but
there is a bishop on g4 maybe ninety
five is actually a problem okay so he's
looking at b7 the question is do I need
to cover this no you can always play
Queen a5
okay yeah I cannot Castle yeah I take
play-play 92 winning the exchange
well cannot is a bit strong but it is
close to not possible
now I'm also intending Knight a5 oh it
takes it
interesting
he is ready to castle hmm so if I take
92 Queen b7 he is giving up the exchange
or he blundered it's also possible it
could be a sacrifice it's really
possible
Bishop takes Bishop takes 9225 yeah that
could be actually some compensation
could be some compensation and really
okay I can also just play it like that
it's let's know I don't need to win the
exchange it's not really a given that I
do ideas to play Knight B 3 and then
Queen 285 then c3 is quite difficult to
keep
I'm fine I think I'm fine
yeah don't want to take just just keep
this
let's play I had to take that but on a
three but it's really not a necessity
and if possible I want to keep the
bishop here uh-huh okay
covering b3
this is an interesting move maybe let's
try I mean if he takes it how does he
keep the parts it's not easier
and I can actually keep the pawns okay I
should have thought about this a bit a
little bit more but we need irritated
him enough it seems okay but yeah after
this it's really annoying him so pawn
takes even threatening b2 and now if I
take it I would I would so much like to
put the knight on to c4 I would be
fantastic probably not possible okay if
I get in a four a five a five a four
would be great
what is he doing next rupee one maybe if
I take it doesn't do much if I he will
play for
[Music]
[Music]
hmm what did I miss play yeah it's
really strange
I completely miss played this I'm going
down here now for yeah for compensation
but not for not for a winning position
which I should have something went wrong
there
don't don't really get what what went
wrong here
very weird okay I should focus a little
bit you can still win this position by
playing well quick eggs no I don't want
to trade Queens so take a look at dog
invasion time and there are checks here
unfortunately Ark Queen a5 shoot
Queeny 8 is probably a drool can he
escape and win net would be crazy
Queen h4 Chang would be neat I can get
this one
I'd like to win somehow and now we can
go to d3 and it's drawn and I draw is
terrible opposition was completely
winning strategically winning like here
it's just eh it's just over
it's just over this stuff okay yeah I
was trying to play as sharply as
possible yeah we'll see five I don't
know that could maybe it was too sharp I
don't know but it turned out to be
really nice you know this position is
certainly interesting 95 maybe but I'm
mostly interested in how I spoiled this
it was just a position that you have to
win like here you should just win with
Blacula it's just no excuse for not
winning
really ah-ha there is creepy six okay
then that that is nice this this this
this this this this and I gave this move
to ensure promotion really nice yeah
that was the way to witness that was the
way to win this arc yeah and I mean I
kind of knew that this wasn't right but
I did not find a win and then I I had to
play move man and not lose on time and
then yeah I think in the coming
complications we probably both were
winning at some point we should g7 now
as a winner okay it's not so easy to see
if you have no time I mean it's not
really difficult take a look g1 but I
understand why he didn't spot it and now
I should just win I will gauge force
with medium okay we are taking a pawn
with the check is often too tempting and
here I should also win but I didn't do
it Ruka a7 was a bit of a panicky move
oh yeah it's it should be it should be a
draw and he we had I should check on g2
yeah whatever it was there was some but
some blunders there in this game but I
should really win this position I didn't
see it I didn't see this tactical idea
and the quest problem yeah this is the
simple move but I thought he has a form
I came
since that's something that you can
definitely find even here this is a
possibility and promote and ambled there
was a bad leap like a man I should
really win this position and it's it's
not so difficult ok guys thanks for
watching